[Music]
[Applause]
Brady Quinn former Notre Dame
quarterback Fox college football analyst
big noon kickoff also does two pros and
a cup of joe he's a busy man and uh
Brady and the crew in Columbus on
Saturday Maryland Ohio State at the
Horseshoe got interesting there in the
first half and then Ohio State blew uh
blew out the turps Brady joining us uh
Bea the
uh where do you want to start with
college football this
weekend I mean I guess we can start with
a lot of the upsets um it was one of
those weekends where I think we had a
number of matchups where it was kind of
a a prove it you know prove it your
record Maryland for example was five
and0 taking on obviously an undefeated
Ohio State team and you know I think as
you pointed out they put up a good fight
for the first half and then Ohio State
really took control in the second half
and you could probably talk about a
number of matchups Oklahoma and Texas
same thing I mean I didn't see Oklahoma
really taking control of that game the
way they did and Dylan Gabriel kind of
coming away as the Heisman favorite
based on what we saw so far this year
you know Quinn Ur and Texas have been
much more tested you know given their
big win over Bama uh had a really a huge
win over Kansas which was a top 25 team
at the time Oklahoma played a much
softer schedule but boy uh were they up
for the moment and and you mentioned
Dylan Gabriel's highman favorite he's
got to be right up there next to the
Caleb Williams of the world and and the
Michael pennick right now with the way
he's played so far
um you know Caleb Williams is going to
continue to put up big numbers Brady
because he has to because the defense is
so bad it's not like you can take him
out of a game or change your game plan
they have to put their foot on the
accelerator the rest of the
season yeah and that's that's been the
case the past you know really two years
if you go back to last year I mean this
defense hit the transfer portal hard I
want to say they had five or six uh
starters on their 2D that are that
basically came via the transfer portal
and you know one that that's going to
take some time for those guys to to Jael
and adjust but um the tackling is the
biggest thing that stands out where that
was a huge issue for them last year even
though they were they were decimated at
times with injuries and they were thin
as it was but now this year they're
supposed to be better they're supposed
to be more talented they played a soft
schedule coming into this past week and
you know you figure they should be able
to control more games and they're just
not able to they have to win in a
shootout every single week and that's a
lot of pressure especially when you're
talking about the Pack 12 that probably
has the most parody of any conference in
its final year as we know it and you
know eventually that's going to catch up
to USC it caught up to them last year
they couldn't get B past Utah and
obviously this week they they take on my
Fighting Irish which have issues of
their own but when you look at the
schedule that USC has ahead including
Notre Dame and having to go through you
know team a team like Utah who knows if
Cam rising's back or not but Washington
out there as well and Oregon I mean it
is a gauntlet a brutal schedule that
they've got to play and their defense
has to find a quick turnaround or has to
find some answers
fast I don't know if you remember this
conversation we had in Dublin Ireland
and uh you said to me Duke and
Louisville that that that concerns you
about Notre Dame and and you wouldn't be
surprised if they lost to one of those
two they barely squeak by Duke they
ended up losing to Louisville also throw
in the Trap game with USC in the on Deck
Circle so assess Notre Dame
now yeah I mean I think the one thing we
didn't know is you know how many of
these games would be in prime time you
know you knew Ohio State you knew USC
and then you saw Duke and Louisville get
flexed into it and for people out there
who are probably G to say hey this is
making an excuse it's not an excuse I
mean I experienced it you know Notre
Dame hasn't won back-to-back weeks on
the road for his two top 25 opponents
since I was there so I understand the
difficulty of the schedule and
navigating it and how hard it can be
when you're talking about week after
week after week being in tough tough
tight games physical games and and have
to do it in prime time and then turning
around getting back late at night and
having to deal with everything else to
get back up the next week um I mean to
me watching them they just they look
tired they I mean I don't want to take
anything away from what Jeff RAM and his
staff did and the players did because by
Far and Away Louisville dominated that
game you know I give them a ton of
credit Rong English their defensive
coordinator is one of the better
defensive Minds in my opinion in college
fo football I don't know that he gets
enough praise for the job he does week
in and week out um but Louisville just
really took it to him and look there's a
lot of things that I think we're going
out up front for Notre Dame the
offensive line was rotating some of the
guys up front that's always going to be
tough in a really loud tough environment
to be able to have those guys you know
kind of figure some things out if
they're if they're all kind of
struggling and you're rotating some of
those pieces I think there's some
questionable decisions to that were made
throughout the course of the game and
and the downfield passing that Notre D
was so effective with early in the
season
clearly has has gone to the Wayside in
the past few weeks and when you can't
create some of those big plays like
Louisville did especially with Jordan
that running back and how explosive he
was uh you're obviously gonna have a
hard time you know be able to show up in
some of those big moments so you know
right now you can't feel sorry for
yourself you got to move on you got a
really good USC team coming in town and
uh that that's the tough thing is if if
you're this Notre aame team right now
you've got to be resiliant you have to
have a bunch of leaders and in
particular Sam Hardman who's the Elder
Statesman in the locker room keep he's
got to Rally these guys and make sure
they understand there's a lot of
football left to be played they can't
feel sorry for themselves uh just
because of their performance this past
Saturday talking to Brady Quinn former
Notre Dame quarterback now working for
Fox their college football analyst
explain to me what happened in the Miami
Georgia Tech game how do you come up
with that coaching
decision well I can give you an answer
uh it's not one that I necessarily uh
subscribe to but you know you've got a
player who's on the cus was run for a
100 yards and in the back of your in M
when you're a play caller you're sitting
there saying to him hey let's give
channy the ball let's get him over 100
yards today you're not thinking about
the negative consequences or or losing
in that instance right like that that
almost never happens and so at 99 yards
he gets the football he runs for four he
breaks he gets over it of course he
fumbles so then you're thinking to
yourself okay well they don't have any
timeouts and they haven't done much I
mean is is hannes King really gonna
drive them down the field for you know
touchdown to go win this thing and of
course then that happens so look that
the justification for why you hand the
football off and actually run a play
it's it's never going to matter to
people that's most likely the
explanation behind it um and I think
that's the tough part is for Miami for
this team like those are the sorts of
decisions that when you really boil it
down more teams lose games than win
games and this was an example of that in
Miami instead of putting themselves in a
position where they can move on get the
win it was a tough game and have a shot
at you know playing for the ACC and and
all I mean they got to play UNC this
week it's a tough matchup um you know
now they put themselves where there's no
room for air the rest of the season and
and that was just because of one lack of
oversight for Mario Chris ball or or
lack of thinking about the downside risk
that you're gonna be facing yeah it was
the first thing I wondered when they
were running is is that running back
close to a 100 yards and then I now he
hasn't said that was the reason why they
did it probably you know he's he's
trying to move on uh you know he said oh
I told him to keep two hands on the ball
you don't have to keep two hands on the
ball if you take a knee coach but um it
felt like the dog ate my homework there
uh I want to get your opinion on Brock
pie that how does this happen you play
at Iowa State you're Mr Irrelevant and
now you're an MVP
candidate yeah I mean I think it's it's
a number of things I mean it happens
from his experience his maturity you
know kind of The Moxy he carries himself
with and he's played a lot of football
and so when he gets the opportunity he's
ready from kind of at least a college
experience as far as knowing what he is
who he is and being confident in his
abilities and then you put him into a
position where he plays in a system that
is as quarterback friendly as anyone and
and that's not saying and I've heard
this narrative a lot oh he's a system
quarterback I never really understand
why people look at that as a negative
like I would love to have been called a
system quarterback in the NFL that means
you've probably played in a great system
won a lot of games put up a lot of
numbers had a lot of success yeah you
know usually that comes with that system
quarterback tag but he is in a great
system like Kyle Shanahan is one of the
best if not the best offensive mind you
look at his the coaching tree from Mike
Shanahan and Kyle Shanahan and how it's
impacted the NFL and offenses right now
that are that are successful so he's
with a great play caller he's with
surrounded by a ton of talent I mean so
many different players that can do
different things whether it's you know
Debo or George K or Christian mcaffrey
or um you know Brendan auk who's really
kind of Bloss in all this youed check at
fullback I mean they do a bunch of
different things and it puts so much
stress on defenses but the the thing
that like I'm most impressed with for a
guy who's got what like 10 and0 and his
first 10 starts is how well he navigates
the pocket and still keeps his eyes down
field and then find those second third
windows for guys and and that's hard to
do for veteran quarterbacks let alone a
guy who's played this few games so look
he he that's Justified he should be in
the MVP conversation because that alone
has been Elite this year as far as his
ability to still continue to make throws
under duress outside the pocket but get
him to the right guy in the right spot
the right time uh it can't be
understated the impact he's obviously
had on this team would you rather have
Dak Prescott or Brock
pie uh what team are they playing for
well how about I start a
franchise I mean it's tough to not look
at the body of work of what Dak has been
able to do um I mean I I I don't want to
sound like a flare for the week guy well
I'd rather start with Brock pie but you
put Brock p on a different team like I
don't know that we're talking about the
same success so if Brock p is on the
Cowboys yeah I I don't know that you're
seeing the same type of success theyve
had with the 49ers
okay I'm a Dak fan I'm someone who's
continually tried to you know praise him
for the job that he's done and handling
all of that I mean they they've
obviously had issues on the offensive
line we saw that again resurfaced last
night uh there's a lot of a lot of tough
things I think as far as you know being
the quarterback of the Dallas Cowboys a
lot of things you have to deal with but
I think Dak has handled tremendously
well so I look I would still lean
towards Dak it's not a knock to Brock
it's just I think you put Dak Prescott
on the 49ers he's probably having a lot
of success too yeah I've mentioned this
quite a few times and that is where
you're drafted who's drafting you what
kind of talent M Jones to me if M Jones
was on the ners we would probably be
praising M Jones fair enough to
say yeah I mean look how many
quarterbacks have have started for Kyle
Shanahan and not excelled I mean I think
Tre Lance is the only one that had
struggled and granted what get four
starts in his career there which is
probably unfair to view him off a small
sample size but most quarterbacks who've
been able to play for Kyle shanan have
had success it's one of the reasons why
I call him one of if not the best
offensive mind in the NFL because he
maximizes the ability and the talents of
every single quarterback that plays in a
system are you guys on the road this
weekend we are we're in a uh very
familiar place to me uh somewhat
familiar to some other folks on our big
noon crew will be in South Bend Indiana
nice nice what what kind of Welcome do
you get when you walk
in um hey what's up
[Laughter]
dude what if this was at
USC um you know the the four-letter
words and everything else and you know I
would just ask them if their parents
paid for them to get into school or did
some elaborate cheating scheme to get
them there that sort of
thing I mean how much how much does the
degree cost there is really what I
usually end up saying so wow okay all
right little degree smack talk there a
little entrance there's no love lost
there's no love lost you know between uh
between Notre Dam and USC so you earned
your scholarship at Notre
Dame um I I I mean I'll put it this way
I I went to all my classes I did not
excel at all my classes but I worked
hard I got my degree uh in in finance
and my second major was political
science and I really valued that I can't
say the same for uh for everyone else
you know out there in the college
football World these other schools are
you talking about ler in
particular I did not say I did not say
that I mean I do know this I do know he
took ballroom dancing and I'm pretty
sure that's not offered another day I'm
almost positive did he get an A in
ballroom dancing is what I want to know
I mean based on the dance moves that
I've seen in our free time I would have
to think yes all right that man can
dance he's uh got very Nimble feet you
would you wouldn't think that because
how tall he is yeah very Nimble feet he
Glides across the Dance Floor wow all
kind of remember Wayne's World where
Michael Myers kind of Glides I think was
her name Cassandra kind to her it's
almost like
that uh safe travels there and good to
talk to you again thank you
Brady thank you always good being on
that's uh Brady Quinn some may refer to
him as beo Brady but it'll be the big
noon kickoff it'll be Notre Dame and USA